first let's continue the girl power with
these two best friends
victoria and katie saw the devastation
of the texas storms first hand
and they joined forces to deliver food
to those
in need they got in their cars and
delivered meals to the front doors
of people who needed it most and
victoria and katie
join us now i have so many questions
victoria and katie
hi oh
i'm so happy to meet best friends who do
good things thank you
victoria what gave you the idea to do
this
what did you see what inspired what got
you jump started
uh one i was sitting home with my family
with my fireplace my power and my water
i
was fortunate enough not to lose the
power or the water
so i'm eating and i'm just thinking you
know i need to help out because there's
so many people that do not have water
that do not have power
so i called my best friend katie and i
told her my plan and she got on board
with me
and that's when we started getting
everything together to do it and katie
what did you do when your best friend
calls you and says let's do something
meaningful
what do you spring into action with uh
we
automatically started in college
starting to call a bunch of different
food places
and to see who was open who wasn't we
finally found one
ordered a bunch of food then we
went posted all over facebook got a
bunch of comments
and responses and then ended up calling
a bunch of friends
breaking up into three groups and went
and delivered it to everyone and
victoria i know this
is personal for you because maybe you
recognize what needs to be done because
of your story will you quickly tell me
about that
yes ma'am um so i was in foster care
most of my life through
group homes and um i also been homeless
before
i've i've been hungry before with no
help so i knew that
i knew how they felt cold and hungry so
i just wanted to do something that i
could for anybody and that's when i got
the idea of
let me just spend my money and get
somebody
because this storm is tearing everybody
down at this point
victoria i love you so much and
i know that you guys are paying for all
of this
with your own money and you just
are real-life angels coming to the
rescue and i'm wondering
if i can tag team and become your third
angel
because i want to donate five thousand
dollars to help you
just continue your mission
you know what let's just make it ten
thousand victoria and katie
you have got to keep showing us how
things are done thank you so much
thank you for doing everything you're
doing and we're gonna check back in with
you
and see what you're doing with the money
and like
keep teaching us and thank you because
that is the power
of good friends
you